at CBS News investigation uncovered a
medical scheme that targets opioid
addicts more than 600,000 people in the
u.s. struggle with opioids the President
signed legislation this year that
devoted more than three billion dollars
to fight opioid abuse some recruiters
are using cash apps like venmo to pay
struggling addicts hundreds of dollars
to get a surgical implant that promises
to curb opioid cravings doctors then
bill insurance companies thousands of
dollars for the procedure CBS Evening
News anchor Jeff Glor spoke to one
mother whose son fell victim to the
scheme he said from the very very first
time I used heroin the very first time
he said I was hooked
in March 2016 Debbie berry of Ashland
Missouri got a text from her 22 year old
son Brennan that no mother wants to
receive he texted me and said that I
have a drug problem mom I I'm in trouble
desperate to help her son berry got him
into treatment in California one day he
called her from a doctor's office to
tell her he'd found something to help he
said I'm gonna get an implant put in I'm
here with them and they've done a priest
certification that the in turn your
insurance will pay for it it was an El
Trek zone implants a small pellet
inserted Europe Asians abdomen it
releases medication that blocks the
brain's opiate receptors so if Brennan
used heroin he would not be able to feel
the effects he was so adamant about how
much it would help him did you know he
was getting paid for it
I absolutely did not know he was getting
paid for it a CBS News investigation has
found vulnerable addicts like Brett and
Barry are being paid hundreds sometimes
thousands of dollars in cash to get this
30-minute outpatient procedure
you don't give a drug addict cash money
industry insiders tell us doctors can
make up to thirty thousand dollars for
each simple surgery and the money is so
good
some doctors hire marketers and some of
those marketers employ recruiters who
lure patients with cash we find a
recruiter calling himself Carter on
Craigslist oh hey I was looking for
Carter and we arranged to meet him
at a Hollywood grocery store
is a potential patients he told us the
implant had saved his life and as long
as insurance would cover it he'd pay us
cash too
to get one he told us he'd get us the
cash the day of the surgery either by
hand or via cash payment he showed us a
payment he'd made to a patient the day
before she had an implant but Carter
mentioned a doctor in Beverly Hills he
claimed it made a lot of money doing the
implant surgeries the same doctor it
turns out who did Brennen Barry's
implant surgery excuse me dr. Rosen
Rosen declined our request for an
interview so we tried to catch up with
him outside his office we've been
wanting to talk to you about why
patients are being paid to get surgeries
through his attorney dr. Rosen told us
he has nothing to do with that
Craigslist ad and he has no idea who
Carter is he also told us all patients
must sign this form stating they have
not been paid to get the implants as for
Brennan Barry three months after getting
his he overdosed after taking heroin
mixed with fentanyl I came home found
him I'm in his bedroom and he was cold
and when I got here you saw him struggle
with us you have to fight every day not
to use or not to drink
they say it's one day at a time but it's
every second of every day
and he did he fought it after he died
Debbie Barry learned her son was paid
$1,000 to get the implants you don't pay
somebody to have surgery you don't you
don't prey on vulnerable people who are
trying their hardest to stay alive and
have a real life again dr. Rosen's
clinic billed Debbie Barry's insurance
fifty nine thousand dollars for that
surgery but the plan was willing to pay
only a small fraction of that Rosen's
attorney did not tell us whether the
doctor hires marketers you heart just
breaks for Debbie and knowing what they
went through
Brennan started using three months after
the surgery so does this procedure even
work well so the the implant is supposed
to work for about three months ended up
overdosing just about three months after
when the effects would have been wearing
off you cannot make a direct link
necessarily between the implant and his
death but again this is when the effects
of it would have been potentially
wearing off but in terms of Debbie berry
it has destroyed her world she is she is
understandably consumed with grief she
is speaking out now
um as other mothers are and other family
members who thought this happened to
them because they want to prevent this
from happening from from everything
we've seen this is an epidemic in
Southern California right now it's
becoming a much bigger problem in many
other areas and it's something that not
a lot of people are talking contacted by
so many families - yeah thank god she's
talking out because you see the way in
which this just you try and get help and
then it creates other problems yes thank
you very